ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States
somber so somber you see that no
applause my choice because this has been
a tough week and folks I understand tone
we suffered such great loss at the hands
of a man who we were saddened to learn
is not a Muslim I wanted so badly for
him to be a Muslim even Isis wanted him
to be a Muslim which is proof that
sometimes it takes a tragedy to unite us
Wow look at that tone this is a chance
for all Americans to set aside our
differences no matter which side of the
aisle you're on from the obstructionist
freedom stealing Democrats to the
unamerican witch hunting Democrats we
can't politicize our politics somber
it's in times like these we must search
for answers that's why tonight's theme
is why I know as Americans we're all
asking ourselves the same question why
did this have to happen during my
presidency so many bad things three
hurricanes all these investigations into
my stupid campaign getting trashed
shocked by that puerto rican lady mayor
i mean i've been through a nap tone
sunburn nobody understands how hard it
is for me
somber trump to walk out here tonight -
no applause at all these people want a
clap you can't see them but they're
dying to climb
isn't that right but I know but I told
them not to and for that I should be
applauded okay now
[Applause]
what